une faq aujourd'hui c'est la deuxième
fois qu'une de cette saison on va aller
très très vite on va se dépêcher parce
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
questions il ya beaucoup de choses à
dire d'ailleurs si vous avez des
questions à poser pour la prochaine
facture qu'on préfère la semaine
prochaine à new york vous invite à me le
marquer directement en bas ici en
commentaire comme ça je vous répondrais
depuis les usa ses compagnons niort
[Musique]
est-ce que sur un statut fera des
comparatifs photos vidéos sur des
prochains téléphones genre iphone 11
n'ont absolument pas un stage ne ferait
pas du tout ce genre de choses était des
bus de la tec comment as tu fait pour
interpréter les smartphones qui as-tu
contacter comment ça marche
au début je ne faisais pas prêter de
smartphones jamais été dans une boutique
films et de trois plans comme ça et
ensuite j'en parlais sinon ton meilleur
ami c'est linkedin qui est une source
d'information merveilleuse entre les
problèmes de huawei honor avec google et
la multiplication des modèles séché au
mit est ce que tu penses que chez homère
rattrapera ou huawei en termes de ventes
ça va être compliqué cherry a beaucoup
progressé ou étant adis fille dans la
difficulté mais là on est vraiment sur
une évolution du marché c'est compliqué
à prédire aujourd'hui d'autant plus que
voilà la situation est encore claire
entre huawei et les usa tout cas ces
deux marques la prouesse vache - et ça
c'est assez intéressant à voir
pourquoi ne pas faire de présentation et
de test de tablettes entrée de gamme
milieu de gamme au haut de gamme en fait
parce que les tablettes c'est quelque
chose qui ne marche pas énormément
le marché est un petit peu compliqué n'y
a pas beaucoup beaucoup de ventes dont
il ya pas beaucoup de personnes qu'il y
dix semaines de sueur
quelques-unes mais pas énormément
pourquoi je ne trouve pas de chimie
nulle part en magasin à part le mil neuf
aces eux ils sont encore dépendantes
enfin que le truc c'est que chez tommy
c'est une question de distribution vous
avez un distributeur qui bosse derrière
qui distribue les produits il faut
convaincre les retail heures pour
vaincre les marques un snack darty et
tous les autres deux maîtres chien ont
mis en magasin et de les convaincre que
sa démarche est donc ça prend du temps
ça se met en place a évolué mais il y en
a plus en plus ça quand même
est-ce qu'il est préférable d'acheter un
téléphone haut de gamme qui sautillait
deux trois ans ou un téléphone milieu de
gamme sorti cette année pour le même
prix moi je pense que du haut de gamme
dit à deux ans ne vieillit pas trop mal
pour un peu moins de pertes mais
globalement ça peut très bien marcher
après ça dépend peu des smartphones
c'est un peu compliqué c'est la course
aux pixels est ce pour autant de gages
de qualité photo non le pixel
elle ne fait pas la qualité alors
effectivement s'il portait sur 1 2
mégapixels et un 12 mégapixels quand
même il ya un monde
mais si brodeur canada par exemple 48
mégapixels souvent de faire des photos
en 12 mégapixels parce que vous allez
prendre 4 pixels en un pour capter plus
de lumière ça vous sortira donc une
photo en 12 mégapixels tant que c'est
pas celui qui a le plus grand nombre de
pixels qui est meilleure tant que
général dans la vie tu as 40 ans non
troppo lequel est meilleur en photos
entre galaxies à 7 et l'iphone si ça
dure question tête le à 7
de suite sa chaîne depuis deux ans je
fus gérant d'entreprise de stream une tv
web ça vous dirait un partenariat c'est
gentil mais youtube youtube youtube
youtube et tu feras des rencontres
abonnés oui peut-être plus tard tu peux
me tester en mieux les nouveaux iphone
11 pro ayant fui très bientôt le test
d'encours iphone 10 ou iphone 10 r je
dirais iphone disent déjà stone
attendant c'est votre accessibilité pour
les fans merci franck avec grand plaisir
voici ma question à quand une rencontre
avec les fans à oui ça c'est on me
demande mon double demande peut-être
pour 2 millions francs peut-être point
de bellion iphone desire ou iphone 8 10
r est-ce que la google pixels slide
avant le jour en france si oui quand
s'cusez moi parce que dans quinze jours
ou trois semaines trois semaines je
crois je vous emmène à la new york à des
google donc on en reparlera très
prochainement sangle les google pixels
ont-ils des problèmes de bugs j'en ai
jamais constaté je crois pas ça va très
bien et toi quel monde connecté acheté
en sachant que j'ai un samsung galaxy
note 9 continuité au top non je trouve
c'est une montre avec le webos
les bombes de fossiles marche bien des
cta du webos derrière tu peux y aller ça
fonctionne très bien quels sont les
meilleurs téléphones avec la plus grosse
autonomie alors ça ça dépend des usages
du nombre plutôt une grosse batterie
mieux ça va un écran oled permet de
consommer un peu moins qu'un lcd mais ça
dépend des usages dont que tu peux avoir
une grosse batterie et citer beaucoup
dessus c'est un peu compliqué ça c'est
toujours un peu compliqué à répondre ça
il voulait savoir si rajouter des
valeurs étaient engagés à porter
prochaine vidéo quand je dis rajouter
des valeurs je parle de mesures avec des
objets comme par exemple la température
ok j'ai compris par tout ça il faut des
outils de mesure certains médias l'ont
01net frandroid et et consorts mais moi
j'en ai pas donc j'ai pas de sont donc
c'est compliqué de mesurer ce qui parler
de ressenti
est ce que je trouve qu'il choque oui ou
non mais la température malheureusement
c'est pas possible que choisir entre le
mini flight et le renmin note huit pros
je n'ai pas testé le renmin ensuite
produit malheureusement je peux pas te
répondre lequel de ses mii est ton coup
de coeur lequel concernées tu étais
abonné qui veut un smartphone schumi
performant et pas cher par exemple
compliqué il ya tellement prégnant la
gamme qu'on finit par s'y call me 9,3 et
pas mal mx3 et cool et si on veut le
meilleur rapport qualité prix je pense
que le leur ai mis deux sets reste quand
même très très grosse balle
pourquoi faire des têtes de cons dans
telle nature c'est pas un gros budget
cherche un bon photophone le webp 20
provoque si le court aujourd'hui
oui si tu viens montpellier y at il
moyen de prendre un café ensemble whine
up
oui notre jeu n'est pas souvent à
montpellier mais pourquoi pas feras tu
des vidéos sur un comparatif entre
l'iphone 11 et le met 30
c'est compliqué parce que le mec 30 je
n'ai pas pris en main je ne pense pas
l'avoir en main c'est très compliqué à
la part du wawel ça ce n'est pas si ce
produit sortira en europe un jour ou pas
donc voilà pile et comparatif c'est pas
trop mon truc tu penses quoi n'est
nouveau free boys 3 pas testé parmi tous
les modèles sur ton expériences et
opinions qu'elles seraient les cinq
smartphones que tu regardais pour 2019
2019 mais pas encore terminée bonjour
monsieur greu quelle marque de téléphone
est le plus fiable je comprendrais
qu'ils n'obtiennent pas de réponse
seront pas vous grillez envers les
marques en fait c'est pas ça c'est que
fiable c'est un peu compliqué
aujourd'hui la plupart des mac fabrique
des téléphones de bonne qualité en tout
cas ce qu elle je parle il ya certaines
marques j'ai pu rencontrer avant que je
trouve un peu moyenne mais des
smartphones de bonne qualité il y en a
partout
par exemple on franchit romy on va se
dire bah c'est un peu moins cher à ce
que la qualité pas là n'ont pas du tout
les finitions fombelle les smartphones
ils sont très sérieux donc des marques
de téléphones fiables aujourd'hui voilà
en quoi celle dont je parle elles sont
fiables sinon je vous dirai si ça
n'allait pas c'est quoi le meilleur
entre le mil neuf pros et les one + 7
pro pour moi ne plus être pro devrait
connaître selon toi le meilleur
smartphone pour faire de la vidéo en
restant à prix raisonnable à moins de
700 euros
c'est compliqué à moins de 700 euros je
dirais des iphone reconditionnés des
iphone à partir du 7 reconditionnés avec
une optique de suez pour la vidéo ça
marche bien les petites questions
pourquoi tu ne rajouterai pas quelques
infos écrites sur tes vidéos
j'aime route que ça rajouterait du
boulot quand tu énumères scène caritas
xbla en fait je vais faire des choses
comme ça le studio là j'ai encore plein
de choses à aménager mais je vais faire
des choses écrites peut-être même avec
des flèches des stylos je vais écrire
faire des dessins aude on regardera ça
prochainement
tu penses quoi du mézou 16x s je n'ai
pas testé peut pas peux pas vous dire
penses tu que renmin au-dessus pro
sortir en france
je n'ai pas d'infos malheureusement sur
ce produit pour l'instant que penses tu
de la galaxie au match 2 watch actifs ou
watch 2 ou à chaque type vidéo tout cas
j'ai vu vite fait je trouve intéressant
tu me conseille de prendre le webp 30
light il est cool c'est leur lien
pourquoi ne pas créer une application en
fait la question c'est pourquoi créer
une application qu'est-ce que j'en
ferais si c'est pour référencer des
vidéos youtube pense pas qu'ils trop de
sens un site responsive en tout cas me
semble plus intéressant pour le
consulter sur mobile que faisais tu es
voir youtube
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup digital juno
premier média web
c'était un de 2003 à 2008 avec des potes
c'était sur la sortie de loisirs culture
clermont ferrand ensuite de la média
vidéo et ensuite beaucoup d'élan digital
et j'ai fini avant j'étais responsable
webmarketing d'une pharmacie en ligne
à sainte florine dans 43 oui les trucs
lequel est meilleur entre leurs ennemis
notre fuite et le mil neuf light j'ai
pas testé leur éminente 8 quel con
smartphone perso et quel est pour toi le
smartphone par fait ce qu'ils devaient
concevoir mon perso en ce moment
j'utilise ça le one + 7 propre qui est
vraiment excellent et le smartphone
parfait six poètes consommables
compliqué je saurai pas de dire tout de
suite en tout cas françois que choisir
entre leur ennemi notre 7 et le samsung
à 30
peut-être leurs amis lot 7 quel est le
meilleur smartphone de l'année l'année
n'est pas encore terminée pourrais tu
faire un conseil d'achat en fonction des
tranches de prix moins de 100 euros 200
à 500 euros pourquoi pas à avoir
seulement d'un peu de tact pas se
planter mais pourquoi pas est il prévu
de faire une vidéo test d'une hotte
notre dispute ça s'est déjà fait notre
10 plus et le roquefort 2 oui ça arrive
l'asus rog fundy c'est en cours ou au
récent google conseillerais tu l'achat
s'est pas terminée cette histoire pour
l'instant c'est pas terminé et pour
l'instant il ya tour des astuces même si
toutefois il n'y avait pas le plein
store pour pouvoir l'installer donc bon
ballon pour l'instant mais ça va être
compliqué mais le problème en fait kia
c'est le plat station dupes les stores
et de toutes les applications américaine
facebook
instagram et on n'imagine même pas
l'ensemble des applis qui viennent des
yeux aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est
compliqué au delà de
google au delà du ps store tout est très
compliqué en fait mais bon voilà c'est
pas fini ce n'est pas réglé mon avis je
pense que huawei va réussir à finir par
être une solution mais google je pense
qu'il ya des mégots qui vont avoir lieu
ou qui sont en train d'avoir lieu entre
la chine les us je serais surpris que ça
reste comme ça
est-ce que parfois tu achète les
produits toi même si acheter uniquement
les airs poste 2 uniquement
sinon j'achète pas en france la sagesse
et pourtant 2020 2022 alors 2020 le
début du réseau et puis en plus ça va ça
va s'étendre d'année en année mais je
dirais 2020-2021 peut-être la vraie
année en tout cas où on va utiliser la
5g parce que le fait qu'ils aient déjà
des bornes ce que j'aime c'est un fait
le fait d'en mettre de plus en plus et
puis le fait qu'on ait les terminaux les
smartphones qu'on est les abonnements
aux services mis en place tout doucement
entre le 1008 light et le mine flight ça
vaut le coup de changer non pas de sur
consommation ne change pas de smartphone
juste parce qu'il ya en passe de 8,9
même s'il plus sexy plus elles n'ont pas
pour le moment donc le milieu 8 light
marche et qui remplit sa fonction
pas besoin de changer chez omis 1907 ou
moins de plus cette paix qui vient
d'être présentée quel smartphone choisir
pour moins de 100 euros
red 1900 selon toi quel smartphone
d'entrée et milieu de gamme où un bon
rapport qualité-prix compliqué il y
aurait quand même pas mal mais il aurait
mis à sauter bien pour un budget
d'environ 300 euros quel smartphone
qu'on s'est réduit un peu moins 20
minutes 7 me à 3 ou 1009 lights à jogger
depuis trois ans et elle fans ont
énormément évolué mais sans prendre en
compte leur puissance quel est celui que
tu es le plus aimé par sa taille sa
polyvalence son originalité galaxie fold
très honnêtement même s'il appelle
choses à revoir
c'est très original qu'est les meilleurs
smartphones pour toi que tu as essayé
il y en a plein des smartphones
excellent mais le plus funky je crois
cette galaxie folle une fois de plus ça
c'est ça change
ces nouveaux donc il faut que ce soit
vraiment cool j'ai une question j'ai
envie de changer de téléphone portable
pour s9 ou un sony xperia 10 mais j'ai
le au nord 8 x doit changer ou pas non
si l'on en 8x fonctionne garde le teint
grand écran il est bien il plutôt sympa
le s9 et bien le spy eye c'est pas mal
mais l'instant que 8 x marche hier le
pad surconsommation quel smartphone
choisir pour prendre de très bonnes
photos et pour jouer un très correct
jeudi
le google pixels 3a ou 3 xl que choisir
entre le galaxy note 10 plus et l'iphone
11 promax bezoom secondes bisous est en
train de finaliser le test du rose
promax donc peux pas te répondre pour le
moment
est-ce que tu utilises routeur si oui
lequel non pas de routeurs moins de plus
c'est tout xiaomi 1009 points de plus
c'est t as tu reçu ma lettre en mai j'ai
reçu du courrier je suis vraiment désolé
on va en parler justement leur parle de
la sécu mais on va pas aller très très
très prochainement de courrier donc
voilà je suis vraiment désolé une faute
plus ce mea culpa
qu'est ce qui t'a motivé à faire ta
chaîne youtube et pourquoi faire une
scène sur le thème qu'en fait j'avais un
blog
j'écrivais plein de trucs un peu stupide
qu'il faisait marrer et puis j'ai vu
envie de faire de la vidéo j'ai envie
d'une mettre dans la vidéo et puis j'ai
cette passion pour la tête depuis très
longtemps et puis j'ai testé une vidéo
comme ça au hasard les rumeurs de
l'iphone 8 qui est une de mes vidéos les
plus vues sur la chaîne et je me suis
dit bon fenêtre pourquoi pas à lier la
tête qui est ma passion depuis longtemps
et puis les vidéos voilà et ça donne ça
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt cool est ce que
le son des écouteurs sans fil shiomi que
tu as testé vraiment nulle où il est
suffisant pour beaucoup personne ne
voulut pas vraiment nui du tout moi j'ai
pas trop accroché mais il est correct
samsung galaxy à 50 ou iphone 5 iphone
c'est pourquoi ne pas faire gagner de
smartphones etc
pc ce serait ça te fera sûrement gagner
de nouveaux abonnés alors gagner des
abonnés juifs parce qu'ils veulent
aborder produit moi ça m'intéresse pas
et le côté un peu concouristes mais par
contre récompensé ma communauté et
organiser des concours oui c'est dans
les tuyaux mais là il ya tellement de
trucs que je nage un peu pour tout vous
dire donc bientôt bientôt bientôt la
question quelle est ta marque de
smartphone préféré à tuer le patient par
laly tech et quel est le meilleur tel du
moment pour toi ma marque de smartphone
préféré c'est compliqué il ya plusieurs
jeunes bien pour différentes qualités
donc je n'ai pas une qui me plaît plus
que d'autres as tu une passion à paris
technip l'un plein de passion jeune
garçon curieux de plein de choses donc
voilà c'est un plein de choses quel est
le meilleur téléphone du moment selon
toi compliqué mais ça dépend de ce que
vous voulez il ya plein d'excellents
smartphones de partout donc je peux pas
par contre ça sans langue de bois pour
moi y'a tellement truc cool de partout
c'est compliqué de répondre quel
smartphone est le meilleur entre le mit
9 des pros et le
au nord un violeur violent je pense que
le mil neuf des propositions parfois
peut-être lit mais en tout cas j'aime
bien le design parce que vous n'avez pas
dans kof c est ce que le web et 30 un
meilleur rapport qualité prix que le b
30 pro il ya un peu moins cher
on a passé exactement la même chose on
peut pas laisser loi mais pour moi le
pétrole en tout cas il est très bon si
la question c'est est-ce que je dois
acheter le pétrole c'est ce que je n'ai
pas regretté par rapport à pitre en trop
dans la mesure où c'est le budget qui
fait un petit peu la loi non pour moi il
n'y a pas de pas de regret à avoir le
pétrole est quand même cool il est
étouffé par pitre en pro mais les
tricolores poursuit faire des duos de
façon exceptionnelle avec deux tuteurs
par exemple oui mais par contre il faut
trouver un concept pour l'instant je
réfléchis encore d'ailleurs si vous avez
des idées pour y aller on va en
commentaire gestion des abonnés qui te
l'a souvent poussent des cris de merci
merci à toi et j'ai entendu clairement
c'est qu'à mon père en clamant hérault
où tu habites clermont ferrand où
chanteront enfin à quelque chose noda
n'a pas les mains quand j envoyais p20
light et je voulais passer sur un
téléphone performant au niveau de la
photo vidéo lequel me conseilles tu pour
un prix abordable
google pixels 3 à bien aulas je me
demandais ce qu'il y à un smartphone qui
sort vraiment du lot pour de la vidéo
mais 84 cas stabilité les iphone sont
très très bons très bons très bons
j'ai une question iphone si c'est sous
iphone 7 ou 7 change de téléphone tous
les combien vu le nombre a même rigueur
tous les 3 mois - peu près des fois un
peu plus ça dépend de la période 1900
light menace était tout me fait gagner
un téléphone pas encore ça mais c'est
lorsque tu fais d'un énième question
android ou ios android ios
est-ce que tu étais journaliste
high-tech avant youtube non quand vous
avez des partenariats avec les marques
vous gardez tous n'ont absolument pas la
plupart des produits repart djeuga très
peu de produits se leva sinon c'est
compliqué pourquoi mettre le son de
l'intro six ans je pense pas qu'il soit
si fort j'ai vraiment fais gaffe au
niveau du maître russe ou équilibré
peut-être parce qu'à de la musique on a
l'impression qu'à plus de volume sonore
alors qu'en fait finalement chez tommy
est un modèle de chaque pour
concurrencer samsung dans chaque modèle
c'est ça non xiaomi a beaucoup de
modèles dans l'entrée milieu de gamme
dans le haut de gamme très haut de gamme
vous trouvez pas chômé gros like faq le
top ma question pourquoi non monsieur
alors déjà je m'appelle granet donc il
ya un sac comme mon petit est né en fait
il faisait pas à re il n'est pas reconnu
poulet les bébés qui zigzague rien et je
me moque et le musée va alors monsieur
grehan fessée greu voilà donc quand j'ai
cherché le nom de mon blog à l'époque
eh bien monsieur grand rapport à mon
fils et puis aussi à m'entraîner est ce
que le galaxy a dit c'est un bon
smartphone je les ai vu je n'ai pas
testé mais il avait l'air pas mal
après on est sur une autre île gamin
mais bon et j'aimerais changer de
téléphone je suis tenté d'attendre le
pixel capture en pense quoi oui attend
on en parle dans quinze jours trois
semaines à new york
on en parlera ensemble est-ce que tu
notre passion par la lydec oui beaucoup
pu tester le téléphone vivo alors je
connais personne chez qui bougeait pas
quand tout avec eux donc vive aussi fort
de cette vidéo je veux bien tester les
produits mais bon pour l'instant jeu
malheureusement j'en ai pas quand les
tests du ricoh view 3 et + 3 prouvent du
trois procès déjà fait deux ou trois
huis clos devrait me l'envoyer mais pour
l'instant je veux mourir mais ni le goût
ni nous
wilko view 3 ou chez homère et demi
notre set et je dirais me nots est
acheté un galaxy note d'ici à faire des
plus rentables que lâcheté normalement
toute façon dans tous les cas vous allez
payer le forfait mettre plus cher si
vous ne prenez que votre abonnement donc
d'une manière 2 vous avez payé peut-être
qu'avec l'abonnement vous allez
économiser 100 euros 250 euros peut-être
mais pas sur toulouse et ex favori est
saluée matticks m a dit je sais pas
compliqué peut-être mon ordi je vais
acheter un tel geste personnage pas qu'à
choisir je suis entre le 1008 light le à
40,97 le règne de sacs et même pas mal
est-ce que tu va tester de nouveaux
téléphones chinois pas fou non ce n'est
pas fou fou ne teste pas est-ce que
lecteur d'empreintes digitales du 1008
life fonctionne bien pour les gens aux
mains moites scolaire et iphone en fait
c'est un peu compliqué c'est capteur
d'empreintes digitales optique dès que
c'est mouillé et donc forcément on
travaille néanmoins ses sauts xi et bien
il marche moi c'est toujours un peu mal
mais j'aimerais ton avis sur le meilleur
photophone porte-voix meilleur rapport
qualité prix bien sûr je dirais
peut-être le goulet pixels 3 à 7,3 à
excellent à l'avenir sera tue plus de
revioo d'ordi portable moi je pense
voilà on a fait le tour en titre avaient
chacune pour aujourd'hui c'est un peu
long et beaucoup de choses à voir que je
trouve ça cool et puces très heureux de
pouvoir en parler comme ça des goûts
donc dites moi si ça vous intéresse ça
vous plaît surtout posez moi toutes vos
questions pour la prochaine faq et moi
je donne rendez vous demain mais sachez
que la semaine prochaine on part
ensemble à new york
on va aller voir microsoft parle et non
ôter du côté microsoft avoir des trucs
qui sont vraiment hypra hypra et
pratique et très intéressante vous
invite à vous abonner s'est pas déjà le
cas
vos questions en bas et puis il ya le
mot fait des bisous ciao